I'm Morgan Freeman, Michael Caine, Alan Arkin.
We're here to play this game.
Never have I ever.
They say that we're going to have fun.
I doubt that very seriously.
But here we go, okay?
Here we go.
Have you ever shoplifted?
No.
I take the fifth.
Have you ever wished you had a different voice?
Not I.
Nope.
Have you ever been confused for another actor?
I was in an airport in Dallas and this guy comes over to me.
I'm slouched down in the seat and he says,...
"You're trying to be incognito, but I recognize you."
So, "Oh yeah?"
And he said, "Yeah, you know, Samuel L. Jackson."
"You can't deny it."
I said, "I'm not Sam Jackson."
He said, "You're lying but it's okay."
Have you ever had a job you loved as much as acting?
I'd loved it so much, I'd do it for nothing.
But I don't tell producers that.
I've worked for years with no money just to get on stage.
For the first 30 years of my life, 40 years up, it was act or die.
But then, I discovered directing and writing and teaching...
...and I found a lot of joy in all of those.
I never wanted to direct because I like to go home early.